[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast
live stream number e what number is it
72. 72. i used a variable so we could
slot
72 in there it'll be seamless that was a
seamless slot on your part yes that was
uh it was pretty close to seamless
um so anyway we're getting good yeah
um yeah is the spring equinox in the
northern hemisphere in the northern
hemisphere it is the fall equinox in the
southern hemisphere
so that sounds inequitable
no no it's not inequitable no i don't i
don't actually okay here's a challenge
to all of you critical race theorists
out there figure out
how that's inequitable well it's
inequitable because uh
spring is dawning and that is like 16
different kinds of awesome
and the southern hemisphere is actually
watching
winter dawn which is uh which is
fall that fall excuse me um but in any
case winter is coming
for them and uh so therefore that does
sound uh
rather unfair i mean all right
i'm abandoning this line of reasoning
having uh driven us into uh into
sophistry for no
particularly defensible well that is uh
to in your defense that is exactly what
the critical race theorists
seem to do is drive us into sovereignty
for no obvious reason except for what
self-promotion and
uh being power hungry something um but
today we are actually going to talk a
little bit about that we're going to
start by talking about springness and
frogness and then we're going to talk
about vaccinations
some again as has become our want um
anything else any announcements for the
top of the hour yeah i'm a little
hesitant
on this one because i do not want to um
give any oxygen to ill-intentioned
people but somebody has apparently
started a rumor that the dark horse
podcast has but
five episodes left and then it will
vanish and if this is true
we've heard nothing about it and you
would think we'd be the first to know so
i don't even know why we're talking
about it then we're talking about it
just to uh
kill off the rumor because apparently
well
now that rumor is known by orders of
mine two more people than knew it before
so other announcements are that
uh we are actually going to make more
merchandise at some point
um and because uh people seem to
appreciate some people seem to
appreciate what we were doing back in
december and january of this year and we
haven't done anything since
um but we've forgotten most of the ideas
that we had so
um we have a list including um we were
talking at one point about migrating
songbirds and how
uh the gonads of male songbirds are
quite heavy and so they literally
reabsorb them
during migration and regrow a pair upon
landing in their mating grounds and so
regrow a pair was proposed as one
uh one thing that might show up on on
shirts for instance but if you remember
anything as you've heard here that you
think would make
uh plausibly decent
merchandise go ahead and email our
moderator darkhorse moderator
darkhorse.moderator
um darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com uh with any of those to which
to whom we apologize for the huge
onslaught of um
of suggestions that she is likely to uh
encounter but yes and there will be more
of those
at the end of the hour so apologies um
okay so uh middle of the episode ish
well though early on you're going to
as promised last time uh say something
directly to ibram kendy who did not no
surprise
uh respond to you you know he plausibly
never
didn't know that you had invited him to
respond but uh
that be being that as it may he will not
have lost his opportunity
good uh let's let's talk just a little
bit about
spring and frogs first okay
so um this is as we already talked about
these spring
equinox it's usually on the 21st ish
uh the equinoxes on the solstices of the
of uh
march june september and december but
that can vary because uh months aren't
equal lengths and even though you expect
uh these moments
uh to uh
which means that um the days are now
equitable oh the days are equitable
the photo periods um so the the period
of darkness and the period of lightness
and even that's not quite right
are the same on the equinoxes hence equa
equinox
um but actually that's not of course
true because light spreads
in the way that darkness doesn't right
so
at the point that your sunrise and
sunset
are just making up numbers here say six
eight and six people
actually have more light in a 24-hour
period than darkness because
um astronomical dawn is earlier than
asteroids i
actually remember i don't remember what
the terms are but like it begins to get
light aeronautical dawn maybe i don't
remember
um gets it begins to get light before
the sun is actually over the horizon
and the inverse is true at the opposite
end it's interesting it's a holdover
effect and there are a lot of these
in uh what do you mean by holdover
effect i mean that the
light holds over past the uh
the sunset and precedes the sunrise so
it's
it's a holdover from uh day
at least at the end of the day the
phenomenon of day
lasts past the um the terminus
the phenomenon of day extends beyond the
borders of
um when the sun is visible in the sky i
don't know that holdover effect is that
useful here i think
for me anyway it's more useful to think
of you know
of of light reaching into crevices in
the way that dark with
in a place with atmospheres we have for
now
um you know like light reaches into
crevices and darkness doesn't
unlike say you know on the moon where
you've got these sharp sharp sharp
boundaries between um darkness and light
yep
um well i just wanted to point out
whether holdover effect is the right
term um you know there are a number of
these things
like the fact that winter is actually
contrary to what most people intuit a
period in which the days are getting
longer and yet uh
for um a goodly period it is getting
colder rather than warmer
i mean so that that has to do with the
loss of heat from
the ground and things like that but let
me ask you something about equinoxes
i feel like you and i track this stuff
we think a lot about it we talk about it
with our kids
this is one that i have always there is
a
an element of the explanation which does
not add up to me
oh i did so has there have been moments
when i've been thinking a lot about this
and i i
haven't really in preparation for today
so you may throw me something that i
should know and have known but don't
know at the moment well it's very
stupid of me to have introduced this
into this live conversation but here we
go a live fire exercise
um the question is the equinoxes
are um six months apart
and they are three months from the
solstices
yeah those periods are mathematically
precise what i don't understand is why
the point in our orbit at which day and
night
our equal actually arises three months
after
the solstice because shouldn't it be the
case
that in our orbit we will travel at
different speeds
at the is it apogee and perigee and
therefore
shouldn't the point at which our day
lengths are
even our day and night lengths are even
shouldn't that point be
somewhere else other than three months
out from uh from these two points
it's it's possible so um i mean
it seems not to be the case right that's
that's my assumption is that my thinking
is wrong but i can't figure out why it
is
well it may be that to the degree that
we aren't actually traveling at the same
speed all the time the variation is
effectively noise
rather than we're sort of ramping up um
you know we're getting we're
you know it seems like boy and we're you
know we're
out of our skis here um but it seems
like we should have lost our skis at
this point
um it seems like we should if anything
if there's anything that you might
predict
about the speed of the earth around the
sun relative to its position in its
orbit it might be going faster
might be going faster as it's closer to
the sun maybe
certainly my expectation um faster in a
linear sense faster in the linear sense
not in the
um not in the orbit not in the
uh day length sense yeah right um but
but that seems not to be the case and
um i feel i feel certain that i and
therefore we are missing something in
the analysis of why the speed
um why that wouldn't be happening to the
speed like if that were happening maybe
that would mean that the orbit was
decaying and we were
um you know more quickly than not going
to end up in the sun
i'm not sure i'm not sure about that so
maybe we'll find out from uh
some astute and sophisticated uh
listener
or just someone who's recently taken
astronomy right or gastronomy
i mean i don't think that would help if
they're not hungry they're liable to
think more clearly
so are you telling me you're hungry no
i'm just suggesting that if we find
somebody who's
laser focused on these issues that they
are uh
they're likely to be people who are not
also starving i see yeah
so um i thought
that being spring there's just a paper
that was recently published about uh
frog calls and uh i i worked on frogs
as you were well aware um and uh
it is true that in the northern
hemisphere uh
the spring equinox is a moment around
which many people are beginning to hear
a lot of frog calls
um so there are you know there are more
than 7 000 species of frogs worldwide
um and there are a lot of ways that
frogs um hook up
a lot of ways for frogs to meet their
mating partners um
actually and they do hook up they
that has an extended relationship
um and here zach
um you can just show my screen for a
moment i just i went back into one of
the lectures i've given on amphibians
over the year
this is various um uh frog
reproductive positions uh it's called m
plexus and
uh and it's the male in in gray and the
female in
in white and they just uh they don't
have what's called an intermittent organ
they don't have a penis
or equivalent and so they just have to
touch cloacas and they figure out a lot
of ways to do it so that's uh
that's kind of a hookup and sometimes he
does hook his his
fingers or his toes around around the
female
and um and sometimes emploxes can last
for months
now wait a second did you just say that
no frogs have a penis
yes however you see where i'm going with
this i do you on go go for it
well i was just going to say isn't there
at least
one clay maybe it's even just one
species that i think we have locally
here am i wrong
yeah it's the most basal clade of extant
frogs
escape a day with the type genus basil
escapus
it is a it is the common name is tailed
frogs and they are yes here in the
pacific northwest and endemic the
pacific northwest
and they um it is they're called the
tailed frogs it's a tail
it's it's the it's the remnant of a tail
it is the remnant of a tail that
functions as an intermittent organ
i didn't look i don't remember for sure
but i think so yes
okay but i i boy you know i'm here
talking about frogs if i know everything
about frogs remember there's over 7000
species i don't know all of them
i think escape is true i may still be
the only species that may there may be
more now
um i don't i think it may be used as
intermittent organ
but it's not a very good one okay how
about that so we are now engaged in
escapism i would say
absolutely um but it is interesting that
it is
basil because this is a little bit like
the familiar example that people will
know
is um the egg laying mammals the
monotremes are basil to the mammal tree
so the point is platypus
and the echidnas so people will be
familiar with a characteristic
that was part of the early radiation of
some
clade that persists but was lost quickly
and therefore you only have the
the few species left or in this case
escapus maybe it's one
uh one species but anyway yes so the
exception that uh i wouldn't say proves
the rule in this case but
it helps to demonstrate it right um
so lots and lots of ways for frogs to
get it on
and um lots you know and actually the
frogs that i've worked on
um sometimes give tremendous parental
care to their kids they you know have
relationship
relation relationships with their
offspring um but almost no temperate
species do temperate species
temperate species referring to the
temperate zones where
most viewers probably are as opposed to
the tropics or the or the polar regions
the arctic and antarctic and um what
to the degree that people are in the
northern temperate zone right now and
it's spring
now as of today and they're hearing
these um
choruses of frogs from local ponds those
are what are called explosive breeding
assemblages and
don't worry it's not dangerous i have
yet to find an actual frog exploding
although it could be interesting i'd
feel sorry for the frog but that's not
actually um what it refers to it's these
frogs who have been depending on where
they are and what species
um hiding out sometimes buried
underground
literally frozen solid for the winter in
order to survive the winter like lots of
crazy adaptations that frogs use to get
through a harsh
uh northern temperate winter they are
now
convening in one place that is um that
is a good
site for them to breed in and these
sites tend to be reproductively limiting
for them and so you get lots of speed
often you get lots of species in one
place
and they show up in these um explosively
breeding assemblages explosive i think
really just referring to the fact that
like well last week there was no one
there and suddenly
my god it's so loud i can barely hear
myself think it's an explosion of
of uh of frogs yeah so so question for
you
um i can think of two reasons that you
might have
repeated evolutions of explosive
breeding in frogs and i'm wondering is
there
is one of maybe there's an explanation i
haven't thought of but
do we know why this evolves repeatedly
so i would so my explanations would be
that one
it could be uh the ephemeral nature of
the opportunity
that's probably so to the extent that a
pond uh
shows up and is available for a brief
time there might be an optimal moment
to breed in it and all of the frogs
would have some detector that would tell
them when that optimal moment is
i'm doubtful of this because not all of
the pawns will be ephemeral not all the
pons are ephemeral however
the more in the temperate zone you are
the more important
the seasonal change will be to getting
it getting it right in terms of like
this is the moment when you're laying
eggs because this is the amount of time
your eggs are going to take to mature
into tadpoles and that your tadpoles
will take to metamorphose into frogs and
those frogs have to be of a certain size
and gain a certain number of resources
before the next winter comes or else
they're more likely to die
okay and watch this if the pond isn't
ephemeral it is much more likely to have
fish in it and if it has fish it it's
not so great for frogs there are frogs
that get along with fish to an extent
but
when we typically find one of these
ponds that has just you know thousands
of frogs in it it tends to be
uh fishless so it's so um
oh i thought i thought you were to go to
um to some degree concentrating all at
once
um in upon you know if if sites without
fish
are absent yeah then it could be a form
of predator satiation that was going to
be my other hypothesis
was that the explosive breeding so the
way predator satiation works for
those of you uh who haven't run into the
concept
you have let's say you've got frogs and
they're predators
the population of predators is small
when there are no frogs available to the
extent that those are
specialists and then
if all the frogs breed at once then the
population of predators doesn't
have an opportunity to rise if all of
the frogs bred in sequence so they were
available throughout the year let's say
that
they were distributed across the year
then the
egg predators would get more and more
common or even the frog predators would
get more and more common and they would
rise to carrying capacity whereas
if there aren't any frogs available or
eggs available
then the population of the predators
drops quite low
and then when there is suddenly a huge
abundance of frogs those small number of
predators
eat their fill and are done and the
population their population doesn't have
a chance to rise to absorb all of the
the bounty that is available so by
concentrating it in time they avoid a
lot of the predation that they would
otherwise face
i'm guessing that must be the primary
explanation for explosive breeding in
frogs
it's i would say that that goes in
concert with and it will be hard to
separate
from uh the fact that in much of the
northern
southern temperate zone two there's just
less of it um the northern temperate
zone the winters winters are very hard
on amphibians in particular and you know
all
all
herps all all reptiles and amphibians in
part because they're not endothermic and
so
you know they have to be collecting
their heat from external
um from from the environment and it's
hard to do when it's negative 20 out
right um and so they um they have a
relatively short period every year when
they can actually
you know profit evolutionarily when they
can make a living for themselves and
breed and all of this and so
um there are depending on species either
photoperiod cues
or temperature cues there are cues that
prompt them to emerge
to you know return if they were
migrating you know whatever it is to
show up
and that um that because it is a
short period of time having a fair level
of precision on when the breeding season
is
is also important so i think those two
things go hand in hand obviously
cool well that makes sense um and so yes
we do hear we actually hear
uh frogs sounds like they're ringing in
our
uh backyard yeah i haven't i haven't
looked at we just started to hear them
and i haven't actually looked up what
what they are yet although it should be
obvious there's just not that many
species of frogs here
um and we don't have a pond so i'm not
sure if we have some creeks running
through
um below our priority yeah um
okay so there is an um
atlantic article out this month uh
called this
sack if you would show my screen how
female frogs tune out useless noisy
males
ouch yeah so um i i
at the end of this little discussion i
will um say what i think about that
headline but
um the research it's based on is
actually quite interesting and here it
is just for a minute it's
um published in current biology it's
called lung mediated auditory contrast
enhancement
improves the signal to noise ratio for
communication in
frogs and i'm not going to walk us
through the graphical abstract but i
kind of love that increasingly this is a
thing now that there are graphical
abstracts that accompany research papers
okay so this paper which came out i
think the paper was this month as well
um basically uh
says that um it it walks through some of
the some of the background that that we
just walked through that
specifically and they're they're in the
upper midwest of the us i don't remember
uh
michigan wisconsin illinois something um
these explosive breeding assemblages uh
often have several species in them
in part because these these ponds are
limiting
and frogs being frogs and
don't get me started i'm not going to
spend hours talking about all the
reasons that frogs display the way they
do but it's basically
they use sound frogs use used
vocalizations to attract mates
it's the rare frog that uses other
indicators although
i have worked on some of them and um
and basically you have distinctions
between species based on uh frequency
both both meanings of the word frequency
actually like the the hertz
um that the call is at and also the
um you know the number of calls per
unit time so um you know maybe
six you know six rings per second as
opposed to two
is one version of frequency as opposed
to i don't even remember what
relative hertz frequencies would be so
i'm not going to give examples i'll just
be way off
um and it turns out this research
basically went looking at particular
species hyliscenaria that's
american green tree frogs is the common
name are
effective at dampening environment and
venerable noise
in a particular frequency so the
individuals and they only looked at
females because it's mostly the females
who are listening
to who are making choices based on the
calls of the males
um but presumably the males are doing
this too um
females can better hear the cause of
their own species and so there's it's
it's called the um
where is it i the cocktail party effect
although i didn't write that down just
going to invoke this
it's the cocktail party effect that like
when how how do you know you might lean
into someone not that anyone's been in a
cocktail party recently but
um like that in a noisy environment if
you know that you're trying to hear
someone
wouldn't it be useful to be able to tune
out all the noise right
and when you are in a breeding situation
with a whole bunch of different species
and this
part of the sexual selection on the
species has precisely been
to get the calls into a particular
frequency range in both senses of the
word frequency
then you may be able to basically filter
out the noise of the other species and
so
as much as i hate that headline that the
atlantic wrote in this case the males
that the females are able to filter out
and i haven't yet told you how
um but but these these researchers did
actually find the females are able to
filter out the males of other species
and they are noisy and they are useless
to them right it's not males of their
own species that they're filtering
it's not it's not a subjective judgment
that they are useless they are
right uh medically incompatible
comedically incompatible
and you know the authors of this
research paper did not use the word
useless that was an
editorial snark from the atlantic um not
anything about the original research
which is quite good
um it was croak bait oh oh
yes yes yeah right okay good um
so from the results of this paper um so
there are also a lot of unique things
about frogs
including um they actually have an
additional um
they have an additional tympanum um
effectively so they can hear at a
greater range of frequencies than other
tetrapods we should say all the other
vertebrates that came on to land like us
or like our ancestors did and they also
have
connections between parts of their
bodies that we don't have
and so their lungs are actually
yes being used as as gas exchange organs
but also it turns out as dampening
filters so here's just a quote from the
results
inflated lungs created a notch filter
that reduced
tympanic sensitivity in a select range
of sound frequencies from 1400 to 200
hertz
between the spectral peaks of the call
so
again long run so they're they're
basically they've got these
these well the other thing is
interesting here and i didn't
i can't i didn't have time to go back
and and really check this out but um
originally like lungs is a modification
of swim bladders
like we are lungs tetrapod lungs
originally existed
in fishy fish um as swim bladders to
help
mod modulate buoyancy in the water
column and only at the point we came on
to land and you know
some of the early sarcoptery genes the
lopin fish um
like lungfish you know extant forms that
we have now like lungfish and
coelacanths
started to modify that swim bladder
which was no longer needed for buoyancy
in the water column because they weren't
spending time
in the water column anymore as a
organism as an
organ for gas exchange and so here we
have which explains why it is such a
god-awful design
i mean so how is it a god-awful design
okay you make an organism
right that has incredible an organism an
organ
no an organism okay that has incredibly
high needs for gas exchange
right you make an endotherm that's
burning tons and tons of uh
organic molecules to release uh energy
for heat and
and movement and all of this um and so
the throughput of of gases is
um the requirements are very high and
then you do it in a blind
sack in which everything that comes in
has to go back out and you couldn't
possibly load the thing with enough
musculature to be able to eject
water if you were to fill those sacks
with water so you
have to go your whole life and never
fill those sacks with water because
there's no one doing it right even
hanging them upside down doesn't really
work
um yeah well so uh you know early
tetrapods are not endotherms of course
and amphibians actually have multiple
organs of gas exchange they breathe
through their skin
as well they breathe they're basically
when you if you just
if you spend time just looking at frogs
you'll see that their throats are always
kind of pulsing and that's actually gas
exchange they're actually breathing by
doing that they're not pulling it in
through their mouth they're actually
doing gas exchange
through the skin under their throat um
but both the
separate evolutions of endothermy in
tetrapods
birds and mammals have um have figured
out different ways to basically help out
the lungs
so you know birds uh uh have
accessory lungs in various places little
like little
places of gas exchange and then we
mammals have a diaphragm
right so we have you know we have this
thing that was just a transverse septum
separating
our guts from our our pleural and our
pericardial cavities
um north um you know posterior to that
um and that transverse septum
anterior to that sorry yes um and that
became muscularized and now we call it
the diaphragm and it basically it helps
us
um pull breath but it doesn't it can't
help us get water out of our lungs
in order to make it efficient for you
know
basically every breath you're gonna you
know take in in your lifetime it can't
be effective for the rare case in which
your lungs have
filled with um liquid um
but you know it all makes sense if you
think about the fishy fish as you put it
the fishy fish do gas exchange in a much
more elegant way
than we do right where the um the
oxygenated water
passes through in one direction there's
no need to eject it from a sac
right right um it just passes through in
one well the yeah
the exactly the water passes through the
uh places of get the capillaries which
are the places of gas exchange are in
the gills
and and the oxygen gets pulled out and
then the you know and
and the water then continues back so
it's a natural flow rather than
pulling in the stuff and pushing it back
out which then creates this problem
where you have a tube
in which basically there's an amount of
exchange you're not doing
you know if you think about a snorkel
that was 10 feet long and the fact that
your
lungs you wouldn't be able to get enough
exchange at the tip because you'd just
be constantly breathing back in
the same depleted right air so yeah it's
a bad it's a bad design that we're stuck
with because
initially it was a you know a cool hack
to a creature that um you know for which
it was a sufficient
addition right but we're now we're now
struck with the stuck with a consequence
and there are
gosh one of one of the favorite lectures
i used to give was on the origin of
tetrapods and just
you know i'd ask students in the
beginning after sort of walking through
some of the some of the fossil evidence
and just being like okay now you're on
land
think about every every system that
needs to be fixed or re-upped or changed
or modified in some way and i'm like i'm
i'm not even going to say the answer
here maybe i'll come back in another
or if we're going to do this i'll pose
that at the beginning of an episode and
come back to it near the end so that
people actually have some time to think
about it but
it's not just breathing it's by a lot
right it's not
just oh my god i was breathing water and
now i have to breathe there i
have to do gas exchange in which the
medium that i'm pulling the gas out of
was liquid and now it's gas there's a
whole lot else going on that has to be
solved as you move
from your medium being aqueous as
opposed to gaseous
well i'm looking forward to us having
that conversation at some point in part
because uh in the time since you most
recently delivered that lecture i'm sure
tetrapods have come a long way so no
doubt we will learn
all of the developments that have
occurred in that class well we're a
mobile group in part so we managed to
make progress
yes we or pretend that we make progress
yes we move ourselves relative to
landscapes at any rate yep
um so um
basically you know the upshot for me of
this of this piece of research which
which i love that frogs are doing this i
think this is such
such a great such a great um you know
huge ish like a a
use of an organ they already have on
board um
they you know they basically lack the
head shape or the technology
for noise-canceling headphones so
they've got noise-cancelling lungs
yeah i i think it's they lack the
stick-to-itiveness but
for noise-cancelling headphones yes um
no no no i don't think so i think you
know you don't have noise castling lungs
do you
no i don't think you do well actually i
was wondering about this so let me let
me understand the explanation yeah they
inflate their lungs and i'm
having the sense that what this does is
it just kind of puts tension on
everything and if you imagine the
tympanum suddenly has more tension on it
it's not going to transmit certain
frequencies is that what's going on
um i i would have to look i can't find
the paper now
um i think it's a little bit more
complicated than that
and it's uh it's a pretty in-depth wow
that's not at all what i'm looking for
um yeah i'm not going to answer that
question because it's it's just there's
there's too much here that i might get
wrong too deeply buried yeah so i just
want to before we
uh leave this topic i just want to point
out the interesting
uh yeah keys the interesting
um analogous phenomena that we have that
we can tell
in ours is done at the computational
level
right so we can tell that what of ours
is done at the computation the analogous
process so if you imagine imagine you
know a situation you and i have been in
where we're in uh let's say a tropical
forest
and there's a noise that one of us has
detected somewhere
in and you know tropical forests are
very noisy
places there's a lot of stuff going on
and
the process of saying okay do you hear
that
no well it's kind of a high pitch like
you know get somebody to tune in to
those frequencies and what this implies
is that your ear was picking those
things up all along
yeah but that your mind was throwing out
the data because of course if you were
processing all of the
stuff going on you'd be overwhelmed by
it and so you throw out most of the data
except for the things that are relevant
to you but somebody can call your
attention to somebody and say shift this
thing
from category irrelevant to category
relevant right then suddenly your
conscious mind
hears it um so that's definitely done at
the level of you know i hesitate to say
computer algorithms but
mind games yeah mind phenomena
yes cognitive phenomena so um i do have
a
correction and again i'm not going to
get into all the particulars and i did
not have time to fully familiarize
myself with this article but if you can
show my screen here for a second zack
here is figure uh two
um from this article in which they're
showing
the um amplitude um
that is detectable when the lungs are
inflated
they're higher versus deflated so it's
when it's the it's the lungs
the frogs are deflating their lungs to
get the
um to to get the dampening of the noise
it's not when they're inflated but
rather when they're deflated that they
get the effect
okay the lungs are deflated and that
dampens
the noise so maybe it is the
similar mechanism to what i was
proposing but the opposite direction
like
loosening the tension on a drum possibly
possibly yeah all right but i mean i
guess it depends which frequency they're
looking for but
yeah okay um and
and just to you know a reminder of the
atlantic's headline before we move
from this topic um they the headline was
how female frogs tune out useless noisy
males
um and i would say you know when i first
saw that before i'd read either the
atlantic article or
um or this paper what the hell are they
doing and i thought okay actually the
males that are being tuned out
are noisy yes and useless to the females
who are tuning them out because they're
the wrong species
um but i will say that um the use of the
word useless there
is just unnecessary fashionable at the
moment snark
against males in this case male frogs
and
uh the more the atlantic does this the
more likely they're going to become
useless to a lot of us
wait but in many frog species
the term toxic masculinity would apply
by virtue
of compounds in the skin that um
however yes however in those species
that i'm aware of
in which the frogs in fact do have um
alkaloids or other toxins in their skin
and that's a lot of them
um there's no sexual dimorphism of the
cardiotoxicity
so it's equal levels of toxic
masculinity
and toxic femininity which are in fact
identical and therefore it's
toxic frog affinity um
well right but that doesn't mean that we
can't hold the male
frogs to a different standard just
because they're not right well i'm sure
the atlantic would
yes i'm sure the atlantic would okay on
that note that seems like a natural
segue to you talking about ebram candy
well of course it does yeah
all right so um what i had uh promised
to do here was to deliver
uh what i am going to argue is a
compelling
logical proof that anti-racism the
framework
offered by ibram kendy in several of his
books
is false i'm going to argue that the
implication
of the obviousness of its falseness is
that it is in fact sophistry
and that its purpose is to drive us all
into behaving
as ibrahim kennedy would have us behave
thereby it's a kind of manipulation so
what is the proof well
the proof involves a phenomenon that i
think many of us are aware of
with respect to dogs so the central
claim of anti-racism is that there is no
such thing as
not racist that everything is either
racist by virtue of its action in a
system that is racist
or anti-racist by virtue of its opposing
that phenomenon
and that there's no place that we could
hope to stand so in effect we can
extrapolate this too there's no
colorblind society that in fact society
must be color aware because there's no
not
racist way for society to be structured
so what's the proof
the proof is this have you ever met a
racist dog
yes yeah me too um racist dogs are a
phenomenon
and i'm going to hypothesize why racist
dogs exist
um nothing i'm going to say depends on
this hypothesis being correct
some number of people may be screaming
right now what do you mean a racist dog
never met a racist what are you talking
about well a racist dog
is a dog that uh responds with uh
aggression and maybe fear differentially
based on the race of the people it
encounters and
you know yeah not not against different
colors of dogs but about
right against different colors of people
exactly that other thing may or may not
exist too
but um but let's just say that uh
certainly
uh growing up it was commonly discussed
that some people's dogs
had problems with people from certain
races right they might respond
badly to black people or latinos
and what i understand what i imagine
that this reflects
is that people have fears or
stereotypical responses differentially
based on race
we know that they do that is arguably
racism but it is at least in that same
neighborhood
and because dogs are very tightly
tuned into their owner's needs and
desires and all of this the dogs pick up
the racism or its antecedent that exists
in their owners
and then uh embarrass their owners by
reacting
to people who have done nothing other
than
have a particular phenotypic marker so
all right racist dogs exist right by
some mechanism maybe that one
here's the question though a lot of dogs
don't do this
our dog doesn't do this right right um
are those dogs anti-racist no
my claim is there may be anti-racist
dogs you could at least in principle as
proof of concept you could create an
anti-racist dog if you could train
it to recognize bankers
in the act of redlining or something
like that a dog could
bark in some way right so in principle
there could be an anti-racist dog but
what they're most definitely are so
the definition of anti-racist here then
is uh
working to reduce historical
uh oppression by making the situation
in the moment unequal so as to end up
with equity
is that this is the working definition
of anti-racism okay in principle and i'm
not that's obviously a ridiculous
example i've come up with but the point
is
the redlining bankers right the
redlining bankers is going to be tough
to train a dog to spot that but you know
it could happen and so it were you to do
that you would have an anti-racist dog
so let's
you know give candy his due an
anti-racist dog is conceivable
but what we have is a lot of dogs who
don't respond differently
based on the race of anybody they're not
paying attention to that characteristic
and what that
establishes is that a framework in which
we define
not racist out of existence is
inherently
false not racist is a category that can
exist
in a context where racism does exist
also
and so my point to you dr kennedy is
your framework is bad we can demonstrate
that using a
familiar example from dogs there are not
racist dogs even though
they could be racist and in principle
could be anti-racist
and therefore it is upon you
you can either point out what is
incorrect about
this proof you can ignore it which is
what i expect you to do
thereby suggesting that maybe there's
something to this proof
or you can
[Music]
what would i say one was was that
challenge it
you can accept it you can challenge it
which i would love for you to do
um or you can ignore it which is what i
expect
but for the rest of us i suspect
that one form of pushback will be
in the form that we have become
unfortunately all too familiar with
in evolutionary biology which is that's
not people it's not relevant
right but see that's the glory of this
proof is that
um if the idea is this argument
is logically sound that is to say
kendy's argument
is logically sound but only resident to
human then okay let's hear the argument
about why that is
and you know if i had you know if i had
argued that there are not racist
typewriters you could accuse me
of uh dragging us into a realm you know
that was irrelevant you could accuse me
of sophistry but my point is because
racist dogs are a real phenomenon
it is a proper analogy right racist dogs
let's put it this way racist dogs are a
phenomenon
anti-racist dogs are plausible and
not racist dogs are common and my point
is going to be
amongst humans racists exist
anti-racists exist
and not racists exist and he is defining
them out of existence and
he's defining the third category not
racist out of existence which
frankly uh in modern times is i believe
most of us right and it is the very
definition of sophistry
right the point is it's a hard argument
to field which doesn't make it
true right in other words the counter
argument is difficult to articulate
but that doesn't make it right and my
point is that actually this matters it's
not just
some guy deployed a bad argument it's
that that argument actually has
a moral imperative that it drags along
with it which is it is your obligation
to do what i ibrahim kennedy say because
of course you want to be anti-racist
because what are your other options
racist right right so the point is that
is that is manipulative sophistry
and it needs to end we need to recognize
not racist is not only a real category
but in fact i would argue it is the only
long-term basis on which society can
properly function
right right we have to shoot for a
colorblind society
and defining it as not a possibility and
therefore
to the extent that you are not willing
to sign up for some formulation you're a
racist
that's nonsense and it was martin luther
king's dream
of course yep because he was a wise man
yeah um
so i guess just a just a little aside
relevant to that before we move into
talking about vaccinations a bit
um i think i think the widespread
embrace
of candy's formulation of anti-racism
and
roman d'angelo's formulation of white
fragility
demonstrates that the left of which we
are apart have become a deeply gullible
people um and it's
gullibility is a feature of being a
follower right
of being um and it makes you
pray to authoritarians of course and
once you're prayed to authoritarians you
are probably more likely to accept
authoritarianism
when it shows up on your doorstep
because it sort of feels like it's what
you're doing anyway and isn't it working
well for me
why not for everyone dick dots are
easier to swallow if you're
gullible to begin with so things like
only white people can be racist and all
of them are
or believe all women all the time under
all circumstances or trust the science
right these are these are insanities
like these may these
there's no way that anyone should be
able to say any of those little
little uh sound bites with a straight
face and mean it without irony and yet
we have a lot a lot of people who and
you know and now policy a lot of policy
being made
on the basis that these that these
truisms
um which um which point actually to
a um not a
dumb populist but a gullible populace
are spreading and you know i'm not
saying there's
not increasingly plenty of dimwittery to
go around too but i think it's the
gullibility
um that is um that is really getting to
me this week
right um so in that in light of that um
before you go on i just want to say that
that is my hope in delivering
what is in essence uh a three-line
proof is that it is so succinct
that those who don't know what to say
there is no
not racism there's only racism and
anti-racism which side are you
on has the thing right it's it's
sufficiently small
that you could put it on a card and the
point is actually i know that's not true
and before you tell me the next thing
right that i have to do in order not to
be over with the racists
i'm going to tell you that that
formulation is nonsense that's my hope
is that increasingly
we will be able to take the things about
which people
are bullied into acceptance the
gullibility that you're pointing to
and provide um a very
a very simple method for diffusing that
uh that trap well i feel like um i don't
i don't yet
see it in its totally simple form um you
know in terms of
the the three line proof the sound bites
etc but
you know having a stack of these cards
like actually you know this is something
that that could be valuable to people
that you know having
a stack of cards it's like you know
racist
short definition anti-racist short
definition not racist
short definition this is in the the
field of possibilities like this
is in the solution set option three is
it i'm taking door number three
here you go you're telling me if i'm not
anti-racist i'm a racist no take this
are we done like like that's the
argument right there and
a lot of people find themselves utterly
hamstrung
when faced with this garbage right and
and you know so to some degree
what you've proposed and what we're
doing sort of thinking out loud and
talking it through
is is serving i think one of the things
that we think it's doing and that we're
hearing from people that it's doing is
helping
to give people the language that they
can use when confronted with a situation
but also having something very short and
that then
can be handed to someone else so they
can have it come back to be like
oh oh not racist right
right so um i think that this is an
important thing that we should all be
doing we should all be generating
these succinct uh responses and i think
actually
we've done it before because you know be
hard-pressed to
figure out um whether we were actually
first on this but
we on one of our uh live streams um
responded to the claim that the protests
this summer were um mostly peaceful
by pointing out that uh you know
that so was the kennedy assassination
and world war ii mostly peaceful if
you're going to
you know count the number of minutes it
was mostly peaceful
right which then caught on and so the
point is mostly peaceful
um died a spectacular death as a claim
because so many people realized actually
that doesn't mean a goddamn thing does
it
right mostly peaceful is is is sophistry
it's
it's and where events tend to define
errors and they tend to define movements
that like
rare events are the things that start
and stop uh big moments
right so we should you know generate
these things and in this case
um you know uh dogs are like people
they can be racist that said most of
them are not
why is that not true of people good
candy
yes good um so i just wanted to share a
few
details from there's a class action
complaint in the state of california
against
uh state agencies in california who are
using
crt who are using critical race theory
and this was sent um to us by
one of uh one of our viewers um which
i'm i am grateful
um let's see i want to read you can show
my
show my screen here zach i'm going to
read a couple paragraphs and um
and then a couple more after that so
this is just
this is from october 13th 2020 so just a
few months ago
just to set us up here this class action
seeks to eliminate discriminatory
policies and customs in california state
agencies that institutionalize racial
preferences in connection with
recruiting hiring other conditions of
employment
and which overtly treat people as racial
categories rather than individuals
defendants wade crowfoot and charlton
bonham collectively the defendants
who are acting secretary for the
california natural resources agency and
director for the california department
department of fish and wildlife
respectively have implemented policies
and customs that are steeped in critical
race theory
a branch of post-modern academic theory
which promotes invidious race
discrimination
so just just a pause here for a moment
the california department of wildlife
and the natural resources agency
this is now in places uh where
you know even many of us who have been
well aware of this would have thought
like these agencies should have been
most immune for the longest right like
this is these are actually agencies
that are doing that are that are dealing
with real things out there in the world
that aren't social constructs
later in the piece the
the complaint specifies first crow foot
and the speakers engage in the selection
bias of isolated incidents as
proof of systemic racism so they're
doing this little sleight of hand where
they say
there's a thing that happened therefore
everything is racist
and systemic racism is everywhere
and second crow foot and the speakers
then argue that any disparate outcomes
in society
must be the result of white supremacy
again it's like you know
it feels like a similar point but it's a
little bit different that any
disparate outcomes like any time you've
got differential outcomes
the only possible hypothesis to explain
that is white supremacy so this is
anti-logic anti-science anti-everything
good frankly um and then just one
more section that i want to read from
here
um if i can find it okay zac you can
show my screen again if you like
on page 12. paragraphs 4748
and i will i will post this in the show
notes the substance of the program
follows so this is with regard to
a program uh that one of the defendants
has used in his agency
with with his employees the substance of
the program follows a similar pattern
bonham and his guests conclude without
any evidence that the reason they do not
see people at recreating in proportion
to their population
is entirely due to white racism and that
they would implement quotas and state
agencies to assure racial equity in who
chooses to use california's outdoor
spaces
the conversation begins with a
conjectural claim that black people do
not frequent california's outdoor spaces
in proportion to their population due to
white supremacy and quote generational
trauma
bonham discusses the idea that quote bad
things happening in the woods and quote
approximately 100 years ago in the jim
crow south has led black individuals
today to believe that quote
being around trees is unsafe
my goodness my goodness yes and in fact
we have
so again sophistry and really
that is the central concept to so much
of this so many of these claims are
transparently nonsense
you know we have been talking about the
obvious sophistry
in the idea that if there is a
discrepancy in the number of people
relative to their representation of the
population that that must inherently be
the result
of a bias we've been talking about that
explicitly since the demore memo
right where demora's point was
effectively yes it could be that but
that's not the only explanation that
would generate the pattern it's
obviously true
it should take any room of four smart
people
approximately three minutes to establish
this to a fairly well and yet
years down the road we are still talking
about are we not scientists
right are we not capable i mean even if
you can't think of the proof yourself
right just simply having heard it once
ought to reveal oh yeah
there are other things that could cause
the pattern therefore it does not
necessarily imply it right
um so you know the question is why is
this stuff so sticky
in these cases we have talked on
this program extensively about the fact
that differential use of for example
bike paths or
nature areas does not and in fact cannot
plausibly
be the result of white supremacy right
nobody's keeping anybody out of the bike
lane
so the point is if you go and you
measure who passes you
in the bike lane and it turns out that
there's a racial disparity
it may be the result of something it may
be the result
of what neighborhood different races
live in and therefore how pleasant it is
to bike or how safe
or something like that but it cannot be
that the bike lane itself has any bias
right and you know historically i can
put together an argument historically
as you know after the civil war uh
and uh black people were moving north um
that they would have been more likely to
choose urban centers and we in fact know
that this did happen
and why because people in urban areas
who had less exposure to people who
looked different from them
might have been more likely to cause to
bring grief
to the black people and so people
migrating
out of the enslaved south might well
have chosen to be in cities and so at
this point there may be generations
within black american families
of city life and far less exposure to
um to some of this other stuff and that
doesn't mean again
that nature is racist or that the
choices that those people were making
um were um you know
there was anything wrong with them even
though they may well have been
making those choices in part due to an
understanding
that i think was probably correct that
it would be safer to move to say chicago
in 1880 as a black person than to
uh southern you know farmland illinois
probably let's put it this way there are
dozens of impacts right it may be a
matter of
you know where there was likely to be
work and how easy it is to
commute and there are dozens of things
that may indeed be the result
of past racism and past white supremacy
and the problem is that
people want to import some pattern that
is differential that may in fact have
something to do with racism that may
have existed
100 200 years ago and they want to say
therefore it
means that that racism exists today
which then results in them
leveling an accusation at people you are
definitely racist because you're white
right that is not a logical conclusion
from
the bias no matter how much racism
played
into the original uh discrepancy that we
now see manifest and so
how much better would the conversation
be if we were
actually talking about how these past
patterns that yes
indeed were rooted in racism have
impacts that carry through today
without it functioning through the bias
of people
right which isn't to say biased people
don't exist but it is to say
you cannot do this candy thing where you
just simply assert oh well if you're not
actively anti-racist by this
you know list of criteria here then we
know what you are
right you're part of the problem no
that's not the way it works
and yet and yet he can well he's right
so there is there is a question that i
still
do not have a good grasp on beyond this
sort of like the left is ever more
gullible
like why has it been so widely accepted
why is it getting so much traction why
is there a freaking class action lawsuit
in california
against the directors of the these
agencies whose uh
presumably raison d'etre is about uh
protecting the land i mean like this
this is the last place where crt belongs
and here it is and i'm grateful to the
people who have
initiated this class action lawsuit but
this is you know this is a
one one example in a sea of many and
um of all of those examples of people
actually saying i've had enough i'm
pushing back this is ridiculous
those reflect a tiny minority of the
actual situations where no one is yet
publicly pushing back so they don't know
how to they're disempowered like
whatever it is
well let's try to answer that question
because i think it's hard to say
what precisely the answer is but in a
general sense it's fairly clear
and i must say i've been um frustrated
by the degree to which people focus on
what they call cancel culture
right i feel like there are a lot of
things that are relevant
to our circumstance free speech
questions cancel culture etc but the
the focus on them is wrong and really i
think the answer to the question you
pose
is that the reason that people have
fallen prey
to these um obvious uh
sophistry constructions or softest
constructions
is that there is a penalty there is a
the equivalent of online brown shirts
and their purpose
is to beat the crap out of you if you
show an instinct
towards rejecting these things or
questioning them or deploying logic
where they don't want it deployed
and so in essence what we're seeing is
not that
people are endogenously so gullible
it's that in the context of a threat if
you show
signs of skepticism what happens is
people stop doing that and what it looks
like is yeah people are accepting this
obvious nonsense
and the fact is look come on how hard
would it be to sell the population on
the idea
that there is no sexual binary it would
be almost impossible if there weren't a
threat
attached to it right everybody knows
this because it's so central to all of
our lives
irrespective every single human who has
ever
everybody knows this right yeah so uh
that's interesting and i do think um
that the timing the rise of of
so-called cancel culture and i say
so-called not because i don't believe in
it but just because as you say
you know i don't i don't think it's an
expansive enough term um
but you know it we began to see this
really happening at evergreen in sort of
you know beginning like 2013 2014
that's exactly the moment that like john
height and greg lukianov talk about and
calling up the american mind
as things beginning to change on college
campuses and so i do
think that your answer um you know i you
know i've talked about a perfect storm
having to do with three things and
actually um heightened lukianov talked
about a couple of these things as well
but you know
what you're pointing to basically is the
increasing ubiquity of social
media allowed for pylons
such that you can increase the
gullibility of people in real time
because they're afraid of
the virtual pylons but and then the
other pieces of the perfect storm
include
the widespread um drugging of the
children
excuse me um with with with
anti-anxiety anti-psychotic
antidepressants
and then exogenous hormones and you know
all of these things
and then a parenting style that um that
doesn't allow children to take risk
and explore who they are um but the
social media thing is what really you
know
what really was happening in exactly
that that moment
but i don't think it goes back far
enough so what we what that doesn't
explain
is why when when we were in college
in the late 80s early 90s we saw we saw
this postmartism and we pushed back
against it
and it looked and in fact i found you
know my i think it was my senior thesis
i wrote into the beginning like i'm
seeing some of this
some of this nutsy nutty
stuff in the literature and it's fringe
and i don't think it'll go anywhere but
i do think it bears mentioning that this
is one way that people are thinking
um about um my thesis was on actually
how how it is that um in non-human
primates females
establish friendships and what those
friendships look like
um and to some degree also how
testosterone is mitigating those
relationships
and there was already some of this like
social constructionist stuff in
in that um because anthropology got
taken over pretty early
and i then really thought that
um even though we saw a little glimmers
of it in grad school
and we laughed about it and pushed back
against it in little ways
that there was no way that it would grow
and that it would become so all-powerful
i didn't i did not predict as much even
though we saw it and we pushed back
against
particular instantiations that we ran
into i did not see
the last several years coming well so i
want to
make this into a model because i agree i
didn't see it coming like this
right we knew the danger of it but i
would never have predicted the absurdity
of some of the things that are now
accepted uh as self-evident um
but so there's a question about what
context you exist in
and what my claim is going to be is that
when people
start to espouse obviously nonsensical
beliefs as if they were self-evident
there will be an analog to brown shirts
right that the point is the two things
are not separate so to the extent that
you walk
into a context where people are saying
crazy things where's the
enforcement mechanism well in an
anthropology in a cultural anthropology
department in the 90s the enforcement
mechanism is
you're not welcome in this department
unless you agree to these things we have
the ability not to admit you
and we have the ability to toss you out
um on your ear
if you if we miss you on the first pass
and then it turns out that you're a
skeptic
the numbers were so small that all it
took was one social construction as
post-modernist post-structuralist in a
department
to potentially fairly quickly change the
culture of the department right and the
point is the department is
built to be exclusive and so excluding
people
is not hard well but my point is
departments were busy excluding nonsense
until suddenly they were excluding
everything but the nonsense right so
like that that requires an explanation
of when that what that flip is
well i would argue we see in a
million different contexts some sort of
institution public or private that
uh gets taken over by somebody who knows
how to play office politics and
transitions to my earlier point that
because because departments tend to be
small in terms of number of faculty
all it really takes is one person who's
who's got this
as their mission and um they can affect
change in a way that they never could
in a larger you know they'd be drowned
out they're just they'd be they'd be too
deluded
right diluted in addition to being
diluted
in in a larger population so in the case
of the
um the what we heard in anthropology
departments in the 90s
that thing then made it into the wider
world and so the point that we should
uh have for foremost in our minds is
well for that to have happened
we now need an enforcement mechanism
that mirrors what takes place in an
academic department
that explains the wider context and so
my point would be okay what is that
in this context it's uh largely
um the unpersoning that can happen to
you
online if you show a certain kind of
skepticism and
as proof of concept the intermediate
thing
remember back when evergreen was
supposed to be an anomaly and it wasn't
going to
it didn't matter it was just college
kids overreacting well i was just
looking at benjamin voice's
uh most recent his 23rd episode of his
evergreen documentary that's prolific
yeah and amazing
prolific and amazing and i think as a
result
almost entirely of his work this is in
some ways the most
thoroughly documented historical event
um
at least you know that i've encountered
right the level of minute by minute that
he's captured is incredible but you know
he uses in this most recent video
he juxtaposes um people
saying things with video of them same
people doing things in a different
context and so one of the things he has
is uh jamil uh
who was paid by the college to help
rewrite
the activists this is essentially the
lead activist the one who organized the
kidnapping of administrators and
apparently sent people to my classroom
to protest me and all of that
after invoking privately on his facebook
page the idea that it would be great to
have
white people face witch hunts but anyway
this guy
was hired by the college to help rewrite
the student code of conduct which he had
violated
later the summer following um and
benjamin points to this video there's a
video clip of him and his clique walking
around like and he's flipping a baseball
bat and it's very you know clockwork
orange
kind of craziness right but the point is
okay people are saying crazy stuff on
this campus
where are the brown shirts oh right
caught on video
um so that's the question is every time
you have people
claiming to believe things that no sound
no reasonable person could possibly
believe there will be an enforcement
mechanism
and you may not have put the two
together but that's what's going on yeah
okay that's good or a punishment
mechanism
enforcement punishment mechanism yeah
okay much much more to be explored there
but that's good um
okay we on it we're already at over an
hour here
but we wanted to talk a little bit again
as we have several times about
vaccinations
right yeah um so
you listen to some of the video and i
read these papers and you read some of
the papers too but i don't know how to
pronounce this guy's name
i'm thinking it's gert vanden
bosch okay um this is an independent
virologist and vaccine expert
uh who's also what his uh his
credentials include he's formally
employed at uh
gaffy i don't know what gabby is the
bill and the bill and melinda gates
foundation so these are we've got
three papers um all of which he
he's he's just written and posted on his
linkedin page
and he's also got a few uh youtube
interviews out now
and um and he is basically trying to
raise the alarm about the risk
of mass vaccination of the sort of
vaccines that we've got now
during a pandemic being he is arguing
likely to actually cause anchovies 19 to
become a much worse problem than it
already is and in fact become
a global nightmare um the likes of which
we've never seen that's that's his
statement
that's it that's his position and he
knows he does say
i think he alludes to the fact that he
has a manuscript that covers this
that he is putting through proper
channels but he says we don't have time
which is why i'm posting it in this way
and um so
we really i just you know truth truth in
advertising here
um a friend of mine sent me one of these
papers a couple days ago actually on my
patreon
uh and said can you please can you tell
me what to think of this
and i spent a little bit of time with it
and i will say that one of these three
papers the one that i was sent first the
one dated so there's a march
13th of march 17th and a march 6th and
the march sixth one and i'll post these
all
um on on the show notes as well
the march sixth one is is weird it's
tough to get through and it makes a
bunch of claims that seem
bizarre and i could i it was it was hard
to
hard to parse but the later papers and
you know we're still talking about just
within a few days
of now um are very much more clear
and he's also given a ton of references
which i have not had time to look
through the vast majority of them yet
um but the basic the basic framework
is we are not thinking about this
evolutionarily
and the the refusal to do so
risks a whole lot of humanity and you
know that as
a is a is a base claim
is a perfect match for what we've been
saying from the beginning
that we that we need to think about what
this virus will do
how it will change understanding
therefore its origins
affects what we can imagine it will be
able to do quickly if it came directly
from
either a primary secondary host or if it
experienced gain of function research
and serial passaging in a lab and
therefore
is already sort of pre-adapted as of a
year plus ago
to human hosts these are not merely
academic questions
they actually potentially affect human
health and and and
he brings that into the vaccine
framework specifically
yeah i will say i found these um papers
challenging and there were a couple
places where i wondered if we were
tripping over a language issue where he
agrees he used terms that i think
actually aren't the right terms but that
there was an argument so
i i will say i don't find anything
i don't find that this is like the judy
mikovich
situation where there were claims that
were made
that were simple enough to falsify that
it just red flags all over the place
in this case i don't have that or those
two doctors out of current county
early you know last last spring um who
were making a lot of claims that just
were easily
falsifiable yep this this is not that
this is not bad
and so at the basic level and i think
your summary is right the basic argument
here so there
are specific arguments which i'll try to
make clearer in a second but the basic
argument that we are not thinking
evolutionarily about what we're doing
and we are
blindly stumbling into this landscape we
are intervening in a way that could make
things worse and
not better is accurate and i definitely
think
you know we are long overdue to be
having an evolutionary conversation
about
this virus and our approach to it
interestingly
um i do not find in what i've read here
an analog for the argument that you and
i have made
that we are that these vaccines are so
narrowly targeted
that instead of using a complete virus
by using the spike protein as a
single target that that these these
vaccines are very
narrowly focused and that that is going
to create a concentrated evolutionary
pressure so yeah i gosh i thought i had
seen that in here somewhere but i don't
i don't see it now
um but and and but so that's that's a
particular argument that we have made
so he makes analogous arguments yes so
my think my thinking is either it's in
here and i don't see it
um or it's not in here and it belongs in
the same
discussion there's a whole category of
possibilities that deserve to have
consideration and it feels like he's got
a few
possibilities and they're not always
totally teased apart carefully
but he's proposing a few things right
yeah he's proposing for instance that
mass vaccination during a time of
pandemic
puts puts humanity at risk because
if you if you vaccinate when there's not
when you are
when those who are recently vaccinated
tell me if you think i've got this right
if you vaccinate if you get vaccinated
when you are unlikely to
run into the wild type pathogen out
there in the world
your body will have time to create
immunity to it when you do run into it
but during a pandemic you're likely to
run into the thing that you've just been
vaccinated against
before you actually have immunity to it
and
this may basically produce
a inability for the virus
to uh to adapt and become
immune itself to adapt away from the
vaccine it's not that you
don't have immunity to it because
presumably whatever level of immunity
you don't have you have before
the vaccination his point is that
there is a stage after you have been
vaccinated
the first time and before you have been
vaccinated the second time and had the
period in which for your immune system
to become specifically targeted
that you are effectively weakly
immune and that weak immunity therefore
selects for the invisibility of the
virus to the vaccine
and so this is in many ways analogous to
the thing that you and i are talking
about
which is the narrow focus of our
vaccines now it may be that they can
only be narrowly focused it may be that
there's nothing else
in this virus that actually is
accessible to
uh the immune system and therefore it
may be that there's
you know that there's no consequence to
to what you and i have worried about
but i'd like to know that that's true
rather than just it's something we
assume
yeah but so he seems to be making two
points
one is that the partial immunity
that um people get from this
vaccine on the way to being immunized
assuming they're effective right is an
evolutionary pressure
that these vaccines do not appear to
be good at preventing people from
transmitting viruses that they've
already been
infected with i'd like to know if that's
the case i know that this has been
suspected this has been suspected but
yeah i saw that claim here too and
there's no reference like i don't i
don't know this to be true right but
let's say
it is true his point is that what we are
effectively doing is
creating what is
to un unfortunately is the same word i
just used in effect
like running a gain of function
experiment
with humanity by creating a concentrated
evolutionary
pressure for the invisibility and
he imagines that very disastrous things
could be the result of this which i
don't think are certain but are
plausible as far as i can tell
so i i agree um he also argues
um and i again i think you may be able
to add clarity to this because i wasn't
sure
exactly what his argument was he argued
something like
given that older people given that
kovid absent the regime of vaccination
has affected older people more and more
seriously as everyone on the planet
knows at this point
therefore older people are being
vaccinated first
which would appear to be the appropriate
move
but that leaves a situation in which the
way that the viru
another way that the virus may evolve in
response to this
if there is a basically and i'm adding
this here but especially if there's a
slow if you know if the goal is to get
everyone vaccinated if there's a slow
and then and the virus
can't get purchased on increasing
numbers of
of the older population that is going to
evolve precisely to become
more likely to infect younger people and
he argues i believe
in one of these papers that because we
also have at the same time
children who have been pretty isolated
for a long time and
who are now about to go back into
schools um that this may create
uh sort of a perfect petri dish
situation well i don't let me let me let
me clean up
by this let me clarify his argument just
so we know at least not we're talking
about okay so he makes
um two arguments the first one
related to what we've already talked
about is that our behavior
deploying what he says are prophylactic
vaccines in the midst
of a pandemic so his his point is
and he makes very clear he's not an
anti-vaxxer he's very provax
but his point is look if you were to
deploy these vaccines in advance
of a pathogen arriving somewhere it
might be very effective at ratcheting up
the immune response so that the virus
would not get a purchase on the
population
if you do it in the context of a
pandemic already in motion
his point is what you're doing is you
are confronting a virus which has the
capacity to evolve
with a concentrated selection pressure
with a selection pressure and his point
is it cannot help but push this virus
into uh an arms race which i think is
right and is consistent with what you
and i have said
um and that that arms race is very
likely to have these other consequences
which is where this point about
young people versus old people comes up
just one point of order though you said
that he says and i see it in the papers
too he calls it prophylactic vaccine
that seems redundant to me vaccines are
inherently prophylactic prophylaxis
being about prevention
right rather than retreating of symptoms
it's an individual versus population
level question when he says a
prophylactic vaccine he's talking about
the population
level um and for an individual yes it's
prophylactic either way so you think
that his argument there
is that the vaccine itself is designed
to be prophylactic at a population level
and it is being used in a situation
where the population has already been so
widely exposed and continues to be
exposed
that it is not being deployed in a way
that is consistent with prophylaxis
right so and there is a very powerful
evolutionary argument here which is
it is the arms race that creates the
ferocious enemy
right and so you do not want to
invite an arms race you cannot win and
in this case the point is we're making
this move
because we don't have another right and
so we're making a move that we shouldn't
make because what it's going to do is
turn our enemy much more dangerous than
it is
and i'm not saying that that's true i
think there are ways in which this could
be false but it is not obvious to me
that it is false
right and i in fact the arms race part
of it is almost certain to be true
so the second part of the argument and
there is one part of this
that may be well known but i don't know
it and so i i'm
cautious about it but his point is that
actually by keeping
young people um away from
each other and society that we are
weakening their
what's called innate immunity so and he
deploys a model that i think is
is quite valuable the way he puts it
basically that
we start out with innate immunity that
is to say an immune system
in our lives in our lives as neonates
right that doesn't have to
um generate novel insight so when we get
sick with something like the flu we've
never seen it before it gets past our
defenses and then we build
an immunity to it and then we build a
memory of that immunity
right so that is adaptive immunity and
it's actually
one of the most marvelous evolutionary
stories there is it's an evolution that
takes place
in your lifetime inside your body
between your cells
so young people have the innate immunity
but it is not programmed with the
adaptive component which result which
results from encounters with things in
the world
we expect our adaptive humanity to get
better over time right
and so the model he deploys is
over time as you as you age your
innate immunity weakens you get more
vulnerable but your
adaptive immunity grows better because
it has seen the things in your
environment for the most part and it
becomes wise
right it becomes wise exactly and so the
point is older people are feeble with
respect to their ability to keep
stuff out but they're better with
respect to being able to fight stuff
that their immune system is aware of
um now the part of this that i think is
insecure and it may be that it is well
known the part of his argument that you
think is insecure
i mean my understanding it's right there
to the left of the
oh yeah my understanding of this is all
kind of old because uh
came from a course that involved that
textbook but
um in any case the the
argument he he makes is that
the innate immunity and he uses a bad
analogy but if we can correct it
i think what he means to say is that the
innate immunity is in some sense like a
muscle
that to the extent that your innate
immunity is not
encountering things in the wild it
stands down
it atrophies and so by isolating
young people that we would be reducing
their capacity to fend off
you know why are young people immune to
this it's not because their immune
systems are aware of covet it's because
their immune systems are good at
generally dealing with stuff
and preventing it from getting in your
cells they don't have adaptive immunity
they do have very strong innate immunity
this does raise the question of why so
many pathogens are so much
more likely to attack young people
but um to generalize further what you're
saying by analogy to muscles is what he
is saying
um the argument is that innate immunity
is anti-fragile
right that it becomes it becomes better
with insult it becomes better with
pressures against it
right and so anyway i want to know
there's there's
and the problem is there are two
arguments that overlap so um
george carlin had a very famous routine
in which he argued that
he didn't get sick because he had swam
in the hudson and you know
right but anyway so the the police
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
argument right right and the point is we
know that this will have some
some reality over an adaptive immunity
space that in effect the challenges
cause your immunity to learn about
things in the environment
the argument that it's happening on the
innate immunity may be true but i want
to see the evidence that it is
yeah this was exactly one of the places
i hung up too
like i don't i don't know about this
claim and but
but anyway the consequence of all of
this is his point is we are creating
a what he is arguing is effectively a
perfect storm
in which we are setting up an arms race
with the virus
where the virus will mutate away into
invisibility to the immune system
so we will educate the immune system
basically like putting up a wanted
poster
in the post office that alerts the
immune system to
who it's looking for the enemy will
disguise itself
and be able to uh to
move in without uh being spotted
and that that will then result in
it honing in on young people who have
not
been exposed and are therefore
vulnerable
and basically they would be a reservoir
of
potential potential victims of the virus
and that this could create
a catastrophe so
i think where i come out on this is
this argument definitely needs to be
heard
what i don't want and what we are forced
to effectively by the way
that we are dealing with um this
pandemic
is i don't want either people with
perverse incentives
to tell us why this isn't true right
what i want is people who are
immune to pressure right and
aware of various different relevant
aspects of this
to be able to have a conversation in
which they determine because effectively
what he's arguing
is that we should pull these vaccines
right that we are in fact
going to destroy herd immunity which
would grow right
grow with huge costs right we are going
to destroy the herd immunity that we've
already
inadvertently invested so heavily in and
create effectively a novel and much
worse
much more effective pandemic now
that is a plausible argument is it a
true argument
i can see ways in which it could be i
can also see reasons that it might not
be yet but the discussion is where you
would find that out you need people
who are sophisticated about the
evolutionary stuff to have
um you know a candid conversation with
each other about what would the effect
of this be if x y or z
and i have very little doubt we're not
going to get that discussion
yeah no i i agree so i uh
boy i don't know where that leaves us um
i think uh you know i'm
i'm glad that this that he's out there
saying what he's saying and i would
like the conversations between people
who are interested in truth and who do
not have perverse incentives to be
happening
and um instead there's
it just seems like there's a rapid fire
exchange of
is this true is this true this is true
and no it couldn't be because
it doesn't suit my worldview responses
well i would say i see that but i also
think that you know
the most frustrating aspect is
why are people dealing with this as if
they are not intervening in a complex
system
right this is something that you and i
have been saying consistently which is
you're dealing with the most complex of
complex systems you're talking about
intervening
in immunity where you have you know
evolutionary phenomenon on the part of
the immune system evolutionary phenomena
on the part of
uh the viruses and interactions so
you know one of the things i don't think
he does say anywhere in
what i've seen is where is the
invisibility
for this virus right to the extent that
we create pressure
to not look like what we already know it
looks like and that causes variants to
emerge that are
more or less invisible to the immune
system well
that can be a permanent arms race we can
keep chasing the virus and keep
reinforming the immune system and that
is likely to have costs
i don't know what they are or
it could be that the immune system virus
finds a hole
in the immune system and the holes in
the immune system
people who have watched our live streams
before will remember discussions of self
versus
non-self recognition that our system
basically recognizes anything organic
that doesn't match molecules we
ourselves produce
right that's an amazing magic trick of
development
that um basically is the basis of the
the adaptive immune response
however because our systems have to not
respond to self
right in order for this magic trick to
work that means that to the extent that
we push
a virus into looking more like us at a
molecular level
it becomes invisible in a way that we
can't chase it and so
what role this has to play in something
like autoimmunity if a virus
becomes molecularly similar enough to
something that you
create yourself that the immune system
can't see it then the immune system
either pursues it and attacks your
tissues or doesn't pursue it and it
escapes and so anyway
you're sick one way or the other right
and so the question you know we've been
talking about autoimmunity as one of the
things
that it ought to be on people's radar
you know uh
cancer ought to be on people's radar
autoimmunity ought to be on people's
radar these are general failure modes
that arise from the fact that this
complex system
is predicated on certain kinds of
assumptions and if you push one way
you're going to end up here you're going
to end up there you're going to end up
there you know
you've got autoimmunity you've got
cancer you've got destruction of tissue
and aging
right these are all failure modes and
we're pushing on them as if
you know we know what we're doing and
the fact is no it's very early in
the discovery of all of the biological
phenomena in question we're not experts
yeah um
yeah yeah on that lightning on that
light note well
i actually found um someone tagged me in
a very useful rubric on uh on
twitter this is jerome lillysworth um
nope zack
um i'm just gonna read uh
his he said i came with a perfect system
that they should have advertised so he's
he's found a thing from yet another
university saying when you're outside
you have to be in a mask at all times
he says i came up with a perfect system
they should have advertised you only
need to do two of the following
wear a mask be six feet away from people
be outside
two of three two of three
yep two of three and that's uh again i
like
i love this for its simplicity right and
it um
because so much of what we're being
handled handed right now are these
simple rubrics that actually
um that don't that don't describe the
nuance that we need to have
much like i love the idea of the cards
that you can hand out to people saying
actually there's three options it's not
racist and anti-racist there's racist
anti-racist not racist here you go
you can think on this later but also you
know
here you go do two of these three things
pic pick two
yeah i mean if you if you really want to
i suppose you can do three but um pick
two and like specifically at the policy
level
wear a mask be six feet apart from
people and six feet of course is this
somewhat arbitrary
number but um you know be physically
distanced be outside
you don't need to do all three at the
same time you just don't
um i agree but i think
built into this is there is reason you
should not want to do all three
right in some sense the policy that
we're being delivered is like why don't
why wouldn't you do everything you can
right and the answer is you know when
you're buying a car
you do not think well i'd like to be as
safe as possible therefore
i'm going to buy a tank right because
you understand
that actually as safe as possible comes
with all kinds of costs you don't want
to pay yeah right like
you know many gallons to the mile right
right so
we recognize hey there are costs what
i'd like to be is very
safe right i don't want to be as safe as
possible because
you know a highway wouldn't work clogged
with
right now with tanks so the answer is
you should
we are all taking on risks we are all
taking on risks and there's a sweet spot
and it you know and the fact is the
funny thing is you and i
uh we took our kids uh skiing this week
and the rubric on the slopes
is very much this when you're in line
you pull up your mask
right because you're not socially
distanced you are outside
so you're probably pretty safe just by
virtue of being outside but the point is
when you're forced into close contact
you pull up your masks and then when
you're not in close contact you don't
need it
and what benefits do you get for not
having your mask up
other times you're making vitamin d
you're
interacting like a normal human being
and therefore your social relationships
are normal and better and yeah
so anyway yes i like that rupert quite a
bit and actually that's a that's a
good place to show the thumbnail picture
for this week because it was going to be
um precisely from from wednesday the
beautiful day here in portland and also
beautiful on the mountain
mount hood um you know perfect spring
skiing a little bit slushy
um but uh actually amazing the the
the runs were so long that you had kind
of
slightly icy conditions at the very top
and by the time you're at the bottom it
was a little wet and slushy and
yeah experienced everything on the way
down yeah go down a ski climb
ski climb exactly yeah all right um are
we there
i think we might be okay well um
we will be taking a 15-minute break and
then be back with
our live q a as we do every time for
those of you watching and not listening
answering questions that you have posed
during super chat
um and uh we're coming up on one year of
live streams
actually just a few days from now so um
i was thinking about putting together
a list of just all the books i've read
from in the last year
um for people and also again sorry
sorry our wonderful moderator
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
if um if people have favorite moments
from the live streams
i'd be interested to know what they are
and be and perhaps put together a
list if you if you have a moment and you
know what live stream it came from
um i would be potentially interested in
hearing those
um you can also ask the mod things like
how do i pose a question and
when's the private q a and such um in
answer to that question
when's the private q a you get access to
that at my patreon
and every the last sunday of every month
from 11 a.m to 1 p.m
uh pacific we do this private q a with
much smaller audience so we're able to
actually look at the chat
and right now at the 11 and up level we
have
the question the question asking period
is open so
like with super chat we never get
through all the questions but we're able
to spend considerable time on some
questions and
if you joined now you can ask ask a
question
we get to interact with people in the
chat who often uh introduce
things that are worth talking about
that's right
um and brett has conversations at his
patreon every month as well
um yeah maybe that's you know there's
the clips channel
please subscribe to this channel and the
clips channel
and join us at our patreons we do very
much appreciate the support
and maybe maybe that is it i will say
again you know
love the people in your life who you
should be loving and eat good food and
get outside
and get outside yeah and if you're uh
listening to this
um come check out the q a's on youtube
that's right all right be well everyone
you